hey 42 here just outside of Munich lies
a sleepy village called fuga right where
the rent for a whole year is just under
1 euro 88 cents to be precise so what do
you get in exchange for your measly rent
and matchbox perhaps a cupboard maybe is
it made a strudel no you get a modestly
spacious two-bedroom apartment made of
stone is is in a dodgy area no few gray
is extremely safe and rather pretty of
you ask me it's even sits inside its own
world and clave people pay millions for
that in America the five gates of
food right unlocked every day at 10 p.m.
blocking off any passage in or out of
the housing complex the residents
actually have to take turns to money
gates house to let struggle is enough to
10:00 p.m. who got logged outside all of
whom have to pay a fee of 1 euro for
coming home late what time do you call
this Steve but but listen see I don't
care if your car broke down on your way
to visit your terminally ill grandma
it's two minutes past 10:00 that'll be
one year's round please but why is the
rent so cheap anyway well foo grey is
the world's oldest social housing
complex still in use the food rice it's
in the Bavarian city of Augsburg and it
was created in 15-20 to house the city's
poorest residents the rent was set at
one ryan Gilder when it was built about
88 Euro cents in today's money and it
hasn't changed since the owners which
are still a same family that built the
complex in 1520 have basically put a big
middle finger up to inflation figure I
was built by a rather interesting bloke
and one of the richest persons to have
ever lived Jakob Fugger from the
little-known wood highly influential
fuga family but more about him in a
minute
altogether there are 52 identical houses
in Fugro each divided into apartments
there's also a town square and the
church but wait a minute before you go
and tell your mum that you found a place
of your own
and
moving to Germany because you're
probably not allowed to live there yeah
sorry
sit back down if the rent sounds too
good to be true that's because there are
strict rules for anyone wanting to rent
their very own slice of super cheap
gated community in Fuger to rent an
apartment here one must have lived at
least two years in Augsburg belong to
the Catholic faith and be extremely poor
without any debt not only that once you
live in fear gray you are required to
say free prayers every day and franking
the fuga family for allowing you to live
there and you must also pray for their
souls this place is like a cult people
usually have a grave dislike for bankers
which the residents of food rhine all
agree with but when residents were asked
about their opinion of the Fuger family
whom themselves were billionaire bankers
their opinion quickly changes the
residents here have nothing but endless
good words to say about Jakob Fugger and
his family upholding them almost as
deities maybe they're just grateful for
the fact that they have a house in a
rather lovely City for just under 1 euro
per year or maybe it's the fact that
they will be chucked out if they agree
if they say otherwise
hmm I'm starting to think they should
maybe rename this place to little North
Korea I'm exaggerating of course it's
it's not that but I'm sorry Lord fugu
please don't have it my grandma so who
is Jakob Fugger why was he so wealthy
and why did he create Fuger I the fuga
family are a prominent family of
European bankers who took over the
infamous Medici family Jakob Fugger was
the wealthiest of the family and he was
commonly referred to as Jakob the rich
by all who knew him Jakob started out in
the textile industry trading with Italy
he then invested in mining and soon came
to control a huge portion of the silver
and copper mining operations throughout
Europe Jakob also owned a bank and
actually minted coins for the Vatican
which enabled him to control a Catholic
faith and thusly control European
politics because at that time the Pope
had his fingers in all Oh juicy
political parts for a short while Jacobs
wealth made his home city of Augsburg
the banking capital of Europe
Jacob was worth the modern equivalent of
two hundred and seventy seven billion
dollars if he was alive today he would
be the richest person in the world by a
mile
but he was no saint a Jacob's path to
riches was paved with deceit and
political corruption some say he was
even worse than the highly corrupt
Medicis he even created his own weekly
newspaper just for his eyes like
contained dirt on his competitors so
that he could get ahead of them he paid
a lot of money for the newspaper to be
researched printed and delivered to him
every week one week he must have read
some dirt on himself in his own
newspaper because in an effort to dispel
the bad press surrounding him and
improve his public image
Jacob created the social housing complex
of Fugro to house the poorest of old
Berg citizens and he made the rent so
ridiculously low with one Ryan Gilder
that anyone could afford to live there
so why was figure I created so that a
ruthless capitalists could try to
persuade the world that he was really
quite a nice guy hey it seems to have
worked even today the residents of fur
gray literally worship Jacob and the
fuga family they've even opened a museum
there to showcase the legacy of the fuga
family so would you listen figure out if
you could all you have to do is worship
a false deity that's been dead for 500
years oh and never come home after 10
o'clock they still haven't forgiven
Steve thanks for watching
meet the most audacious granddad's this
side of a Sunday roast the so called
grandpa gang pulled off the largest
burglary in English history
welcome to the weirdest city in Alaska
Whittier but Whittier is the city that
forgot how to city because it is home to
just 220 people and they all live in one
building